i have
literally
15 pages of thoughts
on that
i scrolled through the document and my
favorite part was the very last line
which was asterisk woman who farted
question mark
i would just like to say i haven't seen
whitney this passionate about something
since the woolsey fires
the giraffes needed help i literally
haven't well there are two other drafts
uh in silmar at bob dunn's house but
that's what i'm talking about like burn
it all down whitney knows every single
you can say like we're like hey did you
see that guy do you mean romero like you
know everybody yeah to be clear here's
why so as someone that i've i've spent
most of and this sounds a little bit
narcissistic and i'm just gonna keep my
insecurity about talking about myself
out of it um but uh because i'm gonna
try to just be of service so so the the
the lot in my life i guess or whatever
thing
that i found myself um a situation
in which
uh
para alcoholism is something where if
you grew up around alcoholism alcoholism
being defined as uh uh being
not having a choice in your anymore in
the way that you are abusing a substance
sex it can be a invisible substance it
can be a person it can be food but you
always say that it's so helpful alcohol
doesn't have to be present in order for
alcoholism to be present alcohol does
not have to be present compulsive
cooking compulsive organizing
compulsive crafting compulsive checking
instagram there it's everywhere we all
have something that gives us the
dopamine we need that we essentially
keep do i mean it's diminishing
dimensional diminishing marginal returns
um which is you continue to do something
despite negative consequences okay what
and this is a relationship where they
stayed together despite negative
consequences and from what i ascertain
it did not seem like either of them
were able to leave because they were
addicted to each other and so love
addiction is something that is like hard
to
be the
champion of because we're all so in love
with being in love yeah and it's so hard
to say that someone's passion we've been
so conditioned to believe that like if
you're fighting you love each other
we're soul mates and we've glamorized
and glorified sid and nancy and all
these relations right relationship movie
stars
yeah um
yeah and and so i think that it's to me
i'm like oh my god finally everyone is
seeing
what i have been going through my play
out yeah in a destructive way and they
see how
like i've always been the bummer that's
like
if you're if you're super magnetically
attracted to someone you want to marry
them after a month you gotta wait it
takes two years to know someone and you
can only do one two texts a day and one
hang a week in a public place and you
can't go to his house like i have all
these rules that make it so that love
addiction doesn't get triggered in my
brain and i work i've had to work so
hard to stay out of addictive
relationships because i think a lot of
people don't don't realize or maybe they
do but it just hasn't been
sort of
publicly shown in a way that makes it
super obvious which is that
uh addictions to people
can be just as destructive in your life
as addictions to alcohol
and drugs absolutely and substances so
you go into a
an a.a room or a narcoholics anonymous
room and you hear people say like uh i
smoke crack and then i crash my car
right i drank nine glasses of wine and
then i sold my baby to a drug dealer
whatever right right
and then alanons who have done no
substances right necessarily because
normally where the control addicts go
i did all that shit sober yeah yeah yeah
because i was trying to make my guy
jealous right but what's interesting
about this love addiction is that there
are no love addiction meetings you know
what i'm saying i think that we disagree
always okay
but people get it's like it's not as
mainstream what does it stand for slaa
sex and love addicts anonymous it also
includes sexual anorexia yeah it also
includes parasocial relationships and a
lot of other things so there's so many
resources out there that we just don't
know about it's free therapy it's free
school and most of us grew up watching
disney movies and see and
essentially learning that like love is
all you need all our favorite songs love
is pain all i need is you i die without
you right these really exaggerated sick
i mean imagine if there was a song that
was like
cigarettes i need you to live yeah you
know i love that one love it's a great
book that sounds like some shit you
would buy a festival ticket too
one point
[Music]
[Applause]